dès 2023 les Îles de la Madeleine
souhaitent mettre en place une redevance
de 30 dollars pour tous les visiteurs
non résidents de 13 ans et plus un
projet de règlement est d'ailleurs à
l'étude et pourrait bientôt être adoptée
avec nous ce soir Daniel pillade qui est
professeur au Département de stratégie
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale de l'UQAM bonsoir
madame Pillet est-ce que les
municipalités ont le droit de mettre en
place ce genre de redevance oui le
pouvoir le rendit donné
depuis quelques années des gens parlent
la loi des civils et par le Code
municipal alors il s'agit de redevance
disant territoriales limité à leur
territoire ou au territoire d'une
agglomération
en aucun qu'on puisse démontrer que on
est dans une compétence municipale en
vertu de la Loi toujours alors des
compétences municipales il y en a
beaucoup et il y en a beaucoup dans
lesquels les municipalités
s'investissent de plus en plus les
municipalités est reconnu
traditionnellement pour donner des
services distribués des services
particulièrement à la propriété des
services en réseau on voit maintenant
que les municipalités s'investissent
beaucoup en environnement entre autres
en lutte au changement climatique et
donc que ça doit impliquer une éco
fiscalité ou les frais supplémentaires
qui sont causés par des activités
souvent qui se sentent par des coûts
marginaux importants c'est à dire que
par exemple si dans une ville une
municipalité comme les Îles de la
Madeleine il y a différents alors là il
y a différentes situations mais des
touristes qui viennent
des déchets supplémentaires des matières
individuelles supplémentaires et
possiblement il y a même de l'érosion
supplémentaire aussi alors donc pour
toutes ces raisons-là on met en place
des mesures techno fiscalité et on dit
c'est le principe de l'utilisateur
payeur donc là il faut que
l'utilisateur qui est pas le
contribuable et qui engendre des coûts
marginaux importants parce que juste par
exemple pour le traitement de l'eau
potterme si on double la population
pendant l'été ben là on doit traiter
beaucoup plus d'eau potable et ça
implique possiblement un agrandissement
de l'usine de traitement de l'eau alors
c'est là où les coûts deviennent très
importants je vais vous soumettre les
propos de Jean-Philippe Meloche qui est
directeur de la Faculté de l'aménagement
de l'Université de Montréal qui dit que
le territoire des municipalités
appartient au gouvernement du Québec non
toujours sous créature du gouvernement
les municipalités et que ce serait
impossible aux municipalités de prélever
une taxe sur une nonne appartenance
parce que c'est ça que les îles dit vous
ne résidez pas aux îles vous nous
visitez vous payez la taxe qu'est-ce que
vous pensez c'est que effectivement les
pouvoirs des municipalités sont limitées
à leur territoire comme je le disais au
début mais et puis effectivement les
pouvoirs sont délégués par des lois
provinciales alors on a parlé ici du
pouvoir réglementaire de redevance qui
est donné par la Loi des cités villes et
par le Code municipal au municipalités
et agglomération alors il s'agit bien de
pouvoir et des pouvoirs qui sont
reconnus aussi déjà ça existe déjà les
redevances on a déjà des enfants avec
les promoteurs on a en plus alors les
municipalités le pouvoir de conclure
pour les infrastructures des ententes
avec les promoteurs elles ont le pouvoir
en plus d'imposer des redevances pouvoir
de le faire est-ce qu'elle pourrait
faire autrement cela dit par exemple il
y a une redevance sur l'hébergement une
taxe sur l'hébergement est-ce qu'on
pourrait décider de taxer davantage
l'hébergement mais là ça prendrait une
entente avec l'Association touristique
régionale parce que justement il existe
des redevances au niveau de certaines
régions dans des champs sectoriels et
qui sont reconnus par le gouvernement
alors on a la taxe sur l'hébergement les
gens s'en rendent peut-être pas compte
mais dans beaucoup de régions au Québec
toute nuitée d'hôtel comporte une taxe
sur les bergement qui est ajoutée et sur
laquelle va s'appliquer aussi la TPS et
la TVQ alors c'est sur le total qu'on
applique la TPS de TVQ il existe aussi
toujours dans un champ sectoriel des
redevances qui sont imposées pour les
constructions nouvelles à proximité du
REM et c'est la Ville de Montréal où les
villes concernées par exemple Brossard
qui applique cette redevance là et qui
la Redonne ensuite qui en redonne
ensuite le produit à l'autorité
métropolitaine d'autres exemples de
taxes et de redevance du groupe en
terminant est-ce que vous pensez que ce
que veut faire les Îles de la Madeleine
d'autres municipalités vont vouloir
faire ça aussi oui probablement mais
peut-être pas avec il faut vraiment
peut-être pas avec la même intensité ou
la même
rapidité disons parce que il faut
vraiment être une destination reconnue
pour pouvoir se permettre là parce que
ça risque évidemment quand on va oser de
la Madeleine c'est une démarche très
prise
qui implique de planifier les transports
parce que c'est pas facile de s'y rendre
et c'est plutôt aussi tirant et et il y
a pas de municipalité concurrente à
proximité c'est certain que si on est
par exemple dans la région de Québec ou
la ville de Québec attire beaucoup de
gens et qu'on est les vies si on veut
implanter une redevance peut-être qu'on
va avoir moins de gens libres
s'arrête là-dessus merci beaucoup pour
votre analyse et votre expertise merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI